okay let's see who else is on the line
here let's go to our caller from the
seven eight seven area code who's there
from seven eight seven hello David uh my
name is Brian this is the second time
caller from Puerto Rico hey Brian what's
going on
well David as you know it was a bit worn
launched an exploratory committee
thereby pretty much propelling her into
a way into running for president and you
know she I find her to be a very solid
progressive candidate who supports a lot
of things that the Americans are looking
for whether it's Medicare Medicaid for
all $15 minimum wage and her stance on
consumer protection is I find very
important okay but I find that there are
progressives that are not fully on board
with her which kind of bewildered me I'm
not sure as to why and my question is do
you think that what why is there some
hesitancy from progressives and
supporting was a good warning and does
that have an effect on Bernie's chances
in running in 2020 does that limit his
chances or does that help him okay so
you're saying is Bernie hurt by
progressives hesitating about Elizabeth
Warren is that what you're saying
no no uh if Elizabeth Warren runs for
president yeah does that help or hurt
his chances in in running well from a
purely mathematical standpoint the more
people that run the more people that any
particular candidate needs to defeat so
in that sense you can say the more split
the field is the more of a challenge any
particular candidate is going to have as
far as why some progressives aren't
supporting Elizabeth Warren I mean why
aren't some progressive supporting any
of the candidates right so we could say
well with Kamala Harris some
progressives are skeptical of her record
as attorney general with Tulsi gabbard's
some progressives are skeptical of her a
foreign policy
positions and some other strange
comments that she's made with Elizabeth
Warren some progressives may be
skeptical of her because of the fact
that while she arrived at many of the
right positions as you pointed out she
sort of had to be pulled over to them
from a more sort of corporate centrist
angle or something like that
I mean you'd have to ask the
progressives that opposed her why
they're opposed to her but I think that
anytime you have a field that already is
strong with multiple candidates by
definition some people aren't going to
support any any one candidate I don't
know that that in and of itself is a
concern okay well I also think that
Elizabeth Warren has always been in
Bernie Sanders shadow lately and there's
sort of like this constructive mole that
many people have form and two limpid
Warren as being the second best
candidate or the second choice and I
think that could have an effect in her
as we head into 2020 well yeah I mean if
if you see her as the second most
progressive and Bernie runs and you're
more progressive than Elizabeth Warren
you probably vote for Bernie right
probably yeah
so I think that that's the effect I like
to hear every candidate yeah yeah I want
to hear from every candidate as well
that's true all right thank you for the
call very much appreciate it